el pozolero also known as the stewmaker
sometimes the cartel needs a dead body
to completely disappear without a trace
in such cases they ship the cadavers off
to san mateo last year more than 300
people disappeared in San Mateo the
first thing el pozolero does is place
the bodies inside a drum barrel which he
fills with caustic soda sodium hydroxide
after 24 hours there's nothing left but
a thick sludge ass to the only one who
knows what truly happened to these
people is el pozolero the monster who
melted them
here we go the Intel we need supposed to
be in this sikarios house looks like
it's upstairs copy that need any help
now I got this okay I'll take a look
around right let's try to keep it
stealthy I just want right there I'm got
you
I'm in oh [ __ ] I've been spotted good
yep got it just moving upstairs all
right let's see what we got okay I got
the intel on el pozolero he's in a camp
up in San Mateo go how far is it we
could use a ride you got a car out there
now something better you ready to fly
let's go you got it
according to the Intel the camp should
be near this cliff elbows delivers a
high-value target he's gonna be well
protected there's a cam oh damn this
one's gonna be tough yeah we could
definitely use some backup on this one
hey you guys need a hand right on time
we're going after el pozolero we're at
the east of the San Mateo base got it we
are on our way we're approaching the
camp from the West I'll meet you there
copy that
I hear this el pozolero guys supposed to
be a hard target how bad does it look
see for yourself
oh damn looks like a lot of trouble
tagged a lookout can you get him Roger
that one less to worry about okay we're
splitting up Weaver can you get to a
good sniper position on the south side
of the camp no problem alrighty i'm
moving in from the other side copy that
we're moving in from the train station
at the east end of camp it's up enemy
spotted I got eyes on a sniper wait for
my signal got it now tango Down let's
move
okay wait a minute I hear something
inside two guys I got the one on the
right you ready ready go good job okay
I'm gonna deploy the drone and seeing
what's up ahead
looks like an old town that's not the
blancas turned into a base oh man there
are guards all over the place that bad
yep be careful one down so far so good
I'm awaiting guys all right let's see
what's in this big building okay I got
him red gloves gas masks he's got guards
with him got it and another one down I'm
moving through
gotcha ok and close to the building try
to find a way in so anything else man I
think he was dissolving somebody like in
a can of acid or something yeah look
pretty nasty come on guys let's move all
right all right I think I found my spot
nearly there careful that's more than
the closer you get only one left okay
I'm in position I have three tangos in
front of me Weaver you think you can
help I got it going in don't let this
guy get away see him won't talk about
naymeer fuel call us if you need it
don't worry man i got this [ __ ] spotted
me guys spotted the puzzle arrows
running going after him where is he
where is yo get away man okay he's in a
white SUV heading for the East End of
the camp following on a bike
got it I'm moving to intercept this
camps on full alert guys we need to get
out of here fast [ __ ] Oh get in the car
where is he where's he where's [ __ ] till
he's moving too fast with the other way
come on man let's go let's go hurry up
the gates closing I am right behind you
Weaver are you okay I'm good fraga
I'm pulling out found a bike guys I'm on
my way
we watch your fire we need him alive I
can't get a good shot this guy's all
over the place stop moving okay guys I'm
clear out of the camp on the road where
are you guys let me know your damn the
whole place is going up
alright i'm heading for the chopper now
damn he's trying to ram the car i gotta
hit his engine i'll try to slow him down
I was on the way guys on this train
where's the chopper where's I found it
ok getting in I'm in the chopper coming
your way
alright i'm on my way guys hang tight oh
no no no no he's not stopping oh man
come on come on I'm trying
cuz it tough one this guy huh oh no no
we're not gonna push my looks like he's
losing control can you push them to the
side I don't know how it looks up there
but that's what I'm trying to do
Danny dodged it hang on guys I'm nearly
there hmm oh damn it okay I got him I
got him I got him yes he stopped I'll go
be careful rides here how'd you get
buddy
hurry up we got cartel reinforcements
incoming hope you get and in you go
adios let's get the hell out of here I
got him in my line of fire will hold
them off I gotta fly this thing
and we are clear gentlemen nice work out
the top mission hahaha man that was
close
you
you